I think that the truly become
implications of Scottish independence
aren't they understood this would be
unprecedented for us if it were to
happen there are a series of enormous
especially kind of economic and
political questions which aren't
answered yet so both campaigns have been
playing a fair amount of guesswork and
find to actually understand what
Scotland go dependent would actually
meet the main incentive for Scotland to
leak argues the yes campaign is that
they would then have control over North
Sea oil so at the moment norsu oil is a
UK national resource and the profits
with are subject to UK tax the European
Union's made it quite clear that it
would have to be applied for membership
of the EU and that has economic
implications which are incredibly vast
everything for our RS and trade or way
through to how to float people and ideas
and businesses the use of the british
pound as a currency all three main
political parties in the UK have also
been really clear that scotland it were
it to go independent would not be
involved in what they call a condoisseur
union with the UK
often Scotland right now it's really
chaos the Westminster political
establishment respect the political
leaders are in kind of panic mode I mean
really every political leader was rushed
or for the border in order to try and
prepare the yes vote from happening so
there are now kind of increasing demands
from England and to a lesser extent
Wales to also have their own
Parliament's and whatever the kind of
results of the independent though that
will continue now like this card genie
is out the bottle one more download the
AJ plus mobile app and join the
conversation available in your app store
now